San Francisco attorney and my friend
Harmon Dylan recently decided to
represent a man who said he was
unlawfully fired by Google for
expressing his conservative views former
Google software engineer James d'amour
was fired in August after he wrote a
memo criticizing the company's diversity
requirements and he also suggested
biology might account for the dearth of
women in the tech industry they both
both join us now to discuss the latest
with the case great to see both of you
James great to see you man thanks for
being here
so her mean what happened I know you
liked took the case to the NLRB the
National Labor Relations Board which a
lot of people watching going oh what's
that but you took the case there what
happened
so James filed a case with the NLRB the
day me was the day he was fired that
happened before he got council and the
National Labor Relations Act which is
implemented by the board protects the
rights of workers to discuss their
working conditions and so the memo that
James wrote falls into that category of
discussing some of the illegal quotas
and other practices that they do at
Google they complained about and so you
were saying that's protected under the
ARB
correct seems like that kind of makes
sense right and so we also got geared up
to file a lawsuit that would cover
employment claims under California law
so the National Labor Relations Board
has a number of regional offices and the
regional office that governs our region
decided that James had a case and so
okay good news with the case now when
somebody's fired they're supposed to act
quickly within weeks to try to have a
hearing and and get that return to their
job so we were waiting and waiting and
waiting and then finally we realized
something's going on and it turns out
that what happened was Google went and
lobbied the Washington office of the
NLRB to that's called an ex parte
contact which is supposed to be kind of
a no-no and even even the big heavy push
from Google on the NLRB and this is a
trump appointee yes so let's talk about
that the President appoints the General
Counsel the deputy counsel and other
people like that but Obama holdovers at
the NLRB decided to overrule the
regional office of career professionals
that happen often protected it doesn't
happen often okay and what really
doesn't happen often is if they don't
issue a memo about
we're James already withdrawn his case
okay so James how are you doing I mean
this has been quite a roller coaster for
you you're now like this conservative
folk hero which I'm sure that's not what
you ever envision happening you loved
your job you lost your job so how you
feeling how you doing throughout this
yeah it's a little exhausting yeah and
are you were code writer we okay so
could I mean I imagine you could get
hired by someone else at this point
right are you working for someone else
I'm still looking I'm still looking yeah
this has hurt him what happened was you
know the thing is in Silicon Valley you
have to understand Google is the
800-pound gorilla and so people are
afraid of irritating Google I mean I'm
using a euphemism here but and smaller
companies don't want to hire somebody
because they want to get acquired by
Google I mean we were here at CPAC this
weekend Google is a sponsor Google as
ubiquitous so it is a real problem so
what's next with your case because the
LRB that's not going back to court yeah
so Laura we withdrew the NLRB charge we
realized they were just gonna sit on it
and not you know take it seriously so we
then have filed a lawsuit in state court
which is a class action on behalf of
James and a number of other workers at
the company we're waiting for our first
day in court which will be in May now
what does this say to other people in
the workplace whether you're a
conservative working in a more liberal
place or whether you're a liberal
working in a more conservative
environment which are not that many if
they're big corporations they're all
pretty
you know you and I went to law school
together and you know in court you have
a supposedly neutral judge you've talked
about that a little bit on your show
today but a judge hears both sides and
then there's some evidence taken and
then there's a decision based based on
that in agencies which is a lot of what
we have going on here in the swamp in DC
a lot of faceless bureaucrats make very
critical decisions about the future of
companies and policies and so what
Google employees may not know is that
Google has an army of lawyers who are
actively lobbying the National Labor
Relations Board to cut back rights for
workers not just in James's case but in
cases involving them discussing their
working conditions with each other
that's a big deal I've not heard that
before and yeah in Google's big butt you
still have to follow the law and by the
way by the way we're out of time but a
survey of Silicon Valley employees finds
that if you're very conservative 89% of
you say you're hesitant of being
yourself at work conservative 70
four percent of conservatives in Silicon
Valley say they're hesitant to be
themselves at work liberals thirty six
percent they're pretty fine very liberal
only thirty percent feel hesitant about
being themselves this is fascinating to
follow every aspect of this thank you
guys for both being here